j'accueille georges de briey
comment savamment jean-claude très
élégant oui je me suis dit yvon était en
pull-over il vaut mieux que je guérisse
christina brialy donc après de vives
autobiographique le ruisseau des sages
et j'ai oublié de vous dire qu'ils se
sont vendus comme un million
d'exemplaires et ça fait des soins
oui enfin ça fait beaucoup pour les
impôts ouais la moitié à bombardier com
mais je mets la maison tu t'en souviens
je les mêmes essayer
oui c'est trop large pour toi reconnaît
l'autre c'est pas moi c'est pas moi qui
ai mis sa place et ça écrit des pièces
et des pièces qui m'a élu et qui va donc
après soixante quinze dates à guichets
fermés du spectacle j'ai oublié de vous
dire et quatre mois aux bouffes
parisiens vous revenez avec un livre
intitulé les pensées les plus grands
acteurs c'est pas de moi c'est moi j'ai
fait la préface et j'ai choisi avec
quelqu'un les répliques les plus
scintillantes
elles sont bien ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on croit toujours que les acteurs
sont un peu con way alors c'est bien
dans ce qui concer perçoit que tout de
même les acteurs ne sont pas seulement
des perroquets vrai qu'ils ont de
l'esprit et d'humour je l' ai vu tout à
l'heure que de la moi j'adore les gens
qui me font rire il ya là beaucoup
escale à une de vous dans le bouquin non
si elle est une de bruel août vers les
haut normands d'accord là mais avec des
gens très très connu mais non mais c'est
surtout des gens qui parlent du sexe de
l'amour
en avant propos vous dites citer les
pensées des autres c'est souvent
regretté de ne pas les avoir eus soi
même et c'est en prendre un peu la
responsabilité voilà bah oui c'est vrai
que je me dis quelquefois quelle chance
sacha guitry avait de vivre avec les
gens il déjeunait avec capuche en renard
octave mirbeau feydeau aujourd'hui on
s'en va un peu plus quoi vrai